-Uh, We need to break up.
-But why?
[speaking foreign language]
[In English] Page 203 for those that aren't studying numbers.
[Teacher speaking foreign language in the background]
[Teachers voice fades and music plays]
-So... What's up with you?
-Uh...
Nothing?
What's up with you?
-Nothing.
Okay! I'll see you tomorrow! Bye!
[High pitched squeals of delight]
[Joy-filled giggle]
-But, why?
-Your feet are small.
-What?
-Well, Braden said that your feet are hecka' small and...
He's right.
But...
I'm gonna-
-But I love you!
-Ew, bruh.
-Your fly is down.
-Thanks, homegirl!
-She never was helping you, dumbass!
-What a fucking loser, bruh!
-Why you no go home and shave your moustache, ah?
You look fucking gross
[laughs]
-Bitch!
-Stupid ass bitch.
-Ow!
Ah, fuck, that hurts!
Come on, Anna, you can do it.
[squeals]
-Oh,  my god, you are such a brat!
-You're so annoying!
-Ok, you're such a-!
-Why are you even here?
-You're so dramatic!
-I hate you!
-I hate you too!
[gasps]
-Please help me.
-What happened?
-She was run over.
-I'm very sorry.
We couldn't save her.
-Honey, it's time.
-I don't want to.
-It's okay.
She'll come home with you today.
[Melancholy music plays in the background]
-Hey, babe?
-Please let me die.
-Restaurant says everybody who ate the lobster mash has food poisoning.
-Please, if there's a God, kill me now.
I'm so late, I'm so late, I'm so late! Ugh!
I'm never drinking again.
-2! 1! Happy new year!
[Party horns]
-What's the point?
Everyone dies.
Everyone you love leaves or dies.
[sobs]
-Oh, my god, this movie is so bad.
-But you're great in it, though.
-Kill me.
-Let's work on this.
-Sorry.
-But you said-
-Nothing you say will change my mind.
-But you're my person...
[yelling in mix of english and japanese] What do you mean you can't spend Christmas with me
you are...
-So selfish!
I'm done.
I'm done with you!
I don't care about you anymore
Do whatever you want, then!
[waves crashing]
-When your grandma was younger, she walked into the ocean after a four-day drug binge
intending to kill herself.
At the last second,
I changed my mind.
You know, Anna Kay
When it comes to death,
Why rush?
We all get there sooner or later.
The only thing guaranteed when we're born are death and change.
As I was trying to drown the thought came to me.
Why not wait for the next wave of change?
Things were hard, then.
I was depressed.
And I felt...
Hopeless
But what if I stayed?
What beautiful things could be waiting for me?
-Christina's room, as you can see
Everything is back in here together
You know, baby
You can die anytime.
What's the rush?